[موسيقى]
صادرات الصين من المنتجات الدفاعيه بلا شك
تتراجع لان المنتجات الصينيه العسكريه
صعبه البيع فهي ليست رائجه مقارنه بما
تعرضه شركات الدفاع الامريكيه والاوروبيه
في الاسواق فهي سهله الاستخدام ويمكن
تشغيلها مع انظمه اخرى
كيف هي غير مالوفه مما يصعب على ايه دوله
شراء هذه المنتجات هذا اول تحد اما التحدي
الثاني فهو بعد شراء هذه المنتجات فان
خدمات ما بعد البيع للمنتجات الصينيه
والقدرات العسكريه مكلفه جدا على ما يبدو
لانها ليست واسعه لاستخدام
[موسيقى]
مثل باكستان المعروف بشراء القدرات
الصينيه العسكريه
وحكومه وجيش باكستان معتادون على استخدام
هذه الانظمه وما عدا ذلك الدول القليله
التي تتعامل معها الصين فان غالبيه الدول
العالم ترغب بشراء المعدات الغربيه
[موسيقى]